so why would you wait until treatment
when you know you need to get sober
right now you do seem to have some level
of willingness that you're you're trying
to like
on some level you're looking for an
excuse
[Music]
i have four months before i'm going to
be admitted to a
30-day program that's a joint program
for alcoholism and
anxiety and depression
but i have four months before i go in
i'm starting to wane
waxing way in between completely
sobering up and going in
as a sober person
or
giving up and
i almost said enjoying the next four
months but
you know what i mean um so any advice
you have is greatly appreciated
nathan
i would say that you are are suffering
from the alcoholics paradox right like
listen you know you need to get sober
you've been intervened on your friends
are telling you you have you've got to
go you've relented to this intervention
and agreed to go to this treatment
center for 30 days it's not coming up
for four months
so the good devil is like well you
should get sober now and then when you
go get into treatment you can really you
know hit the accelerator and create this
amazing foundation of sobriety but the
alcoholic is like i got four months yeah
four good months party time like it's
time to
really accelerate this thing right and i
get that i understand that like look i'm
going to treatment in four months i
might as well go out with a bang right
well don't a lot of people get high the
night before they check in dude i did i
showed up on the doorstep of my
treatment center completely loaded right
like i tried to make the most out of
that last day right i'm not recommending
that no i think
that um
nathan has an amazing opportunity here
because he's got four months
to get sober so that when he goes to
treatment he can really unpack his [ __ ]
and create this amazing you know
foundation for himself
you don't have to wait until treatment
to focus on your sobriety it's been
impressed upon you that you are an
alcoholic i gather that you agree with
this sentiment
and that elevator is going down and
there's no guarantee that if you decide
to drink or use tonight that you're
going to wake up the next day
you could get into a car wreck you could
kill somebody you could harm yourself
like all bets are off every time you
decide to take that substance into your
body there is a good chance that
something terrible is going to happen in
your life and that's something that you
can't control so why would you wait
until treatment when you know you need
to get sober right now you do seem to
have some level of willingness that
you're you're trying to like
on some level you're looking for an
excuse right like you know you need to
get sober you know what to do in order
to get sober you go to an amy it sounds
like he negotiated himself four months
yeah he's trying to i think what he
wants is for me to say it's cool rock it
out for the next four months because
you're going to treatment or he wants to
feel better about that decision that
he's already made for himself
and that's not the right decision pick
up the phone find an aaa meeting near
you show up raise your hand listen find
somebody you can talk to go out for
coffee with them be honest with them
find a sponsor start getting into the
steps now
you don't have to think about this in in
the context of four months break it down
into what you're doing today is your
pillow is your head going to hit the
pillow tonight sober or isn't it what
can you control in your exact
present moment
that is gonna set you up for
being the the most sober person you can
be when you go to the treatment center
i don't know what else to tell you i
mean the answer is pretty simple i think
that he already knows the answer to this
uh so it's a matter of cultivating the
willingness to take that action when the
alcoholic is gnawing on the back of your
brain saying it's okay you can go out
you need to seek out help for this like
don't do this alone you don't have to do
this alone there are communities of
people ready willing and able to help
you who can help instill in you these
tools and help you learn how to practice
these tools that will alleviate some of
that discomfort over time and provide
you with the ability to kind of manage
your emotional state free of drugs and
alcohol that is going to be
super important in
not only getting sober but ultimately
staying sober
[Music]
you